>>> UKRAINE'S HOCAUST
SURVIVORS HAVE BEEN SPEAKING
EMOTIONAY ABOUT THE WAR
THEY'RE NOW ENDURING AND SENDING
A BLUNT MESSAGE TO
PUTIN.
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
>> EARLIER THIS WEEK, A RUSSIAN
AIR STRIKE TOOK ON A TV TOWER IN
KYIV WHERE MORE THAN 30,000 JEWS
WERE MURDERED IN 1941.
JOINING ME NOW TO TALK ABOUT
THIS IS CHIEF RABBI OF UKRAINE
AND SERVES ON THE SUPERVISORY
BOARD OF THE HOLOCAUST MEMORIAL
CENTER.
RABBI, SUCH AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU
WITH US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'VE ALL HEARD THAT PHRASE,
NEVER FORGET, BUT HOW DO YOU
WRAP YOUR MIND AROUND SEEING
THIS HORRENDOUS ATTEMPT TO WIPE
THE HERITAGE AND CULTURE OF
PEOPLE FROM THE EARTH IN UKRAINE
BY VLADIMIR PUTIN?
IT'S JUST, IT'S DISGUSTING.
>> SO I JUST WANT TO TELL YOU A
FEW THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL, THAT VIDEO YOU
PLAYED OF THOSE WOMEN, HOLOCAUST
SURVIVORS, ARE IN AN ASSISTED
LIVING HOME THAT I BUILT WITH
THE UNITED STATES DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE AND IT WAS THAT
VIDEO OF THOSE WOMEN IN THAT
SHELTER AND THEY ALL WENT
THROUGH THE WAR.
THEY'RE ALL SURVIVORS AND IF YOU
UNDERSTOOD WHAT THEY WERE
SAYING, THEY'RE BRINGING OUT A
LOT OF EMOTION AND THEY'RE
DISCUSSING THE EMOTION.
ONE OF THEM WHEN I SPOKE TO HER
THE EVENING PREVIOUSLY, SHE TOLD
ME, SHE SAID GOD, YOU KNOW, MADE
ME LIVE LONG ENOUGH TO SEE TWO
WARS.
I THOUGHT ONE WOULD BE ENOUGH.
I DIDN'T THINK I WOULD EVER HAVE
TO LIVE TO SEE ANOTHER WAR.
SHE SAID THAT WHEN SHE WAS JUST
HOPING THAT TELEVISION TOWER OR
THE BOMB THAT FELL WILL WAKE UP
THE DEAD AND HAVE THEM COME UP
AND FIGHT AGAINST PUTIN.
THIS WAS LIKE THE TYPE OF
EMOTIONS, VERY, VERY EMOTIONAL.
I'VE SAID IT A NUMBER OF TIMES
AND I'LL SAY IT AGAIN.
THE FEELING OF SEEING SOMEONE
WIPE OUT THE ONE MEMORIAL THAT
EXISTS AND THAT'S BEING
DEVELOPED TO BRING MEMORY TO THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE KILLED ONCE
THERE, KILLED AGAIN BY THE
SOVIETS, NOT ALLOWING ANY TYPE
OF MEMORIAL TO BE PUT UP THERE.
FINALLY WE GET THIS MEMORIAL
GOING OVER THE LAST 30 YEARS,
LAST SIX YEAR, PUT UP A
SYNAGOGUE THERE AND OTHER
THINGS.
THEN ON THE TERRITORY OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BUILDING ON TO
THAT SPOT THE BOMB FELL.
I THINK THAT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
HORRENDOUS FEELINGS AND BELIEVE
ME, I'VE GONE THROUGH A WEEK,
TEN DAYS OF TERROR, NEVER
DREAMING TO SEE KYIV YOU KNOW IN
UKRAINE BEING BLANKET BOMBED THE
WAY CHECHNYA, WHAT HE DID IN
SYRIA AND NOW UKRAINE.
AND HE HAS THE AUDACITY TO SAY
HE'S COMING TO FIGHT FASCISM,
COMING TO SAVE THE UKRAINIAN
SPEAKERS FROM THE FASCISTS.
HERE'S KILLING THE SPEAKERS.
HE'S WIPING OUT KHARKIV, WITH
THE MAJORITY OF RUSSIAN
SPEAKERS.
IS THAT HOW HE'S TRYING TO SAVE
THEM?
>> I WAS GOING TO ASK YOU, HOW
TWISTED IS IT THAT HE'S BRAIN
WATCHING THEM, PREYING ON THE
FEELINGS OF PRIDE RUSSIANS HAVE.
IT'S SICK.
>> IT'S SICK AND IF HE DIDN'T
HAVE A CONTROLLED MASS MEDIA,
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO DO IT.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WHEN
EVERYTHING'S CONTROLLED AND
FACEBOOK IS NOW SHUT DOWN AND
HE'S NOT ALLOWING THEM ACCESS TO
THE TRUTH AND TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING, HE'S BRAINWASHING
PEOPLE, I CAME TO LIVE IN
UKRAINE.
I LIVED THERE FOR TWO FULL
YEARS, ENTIRE YEAR OF 1990 AND
'91 IN THE SOVIET UNION.
I'M AN AMERICAN KID.
IN BROOKLYN.
I CAME THERE AND I, WHAT WAS THE
MOST FRIGHTENING THING I SEE IN
THE SOVIET UNION?
I LIVED THERE FULL TIME WITH MY
WIFE AND SON.
THE MOST FRIGHTENING THING WAS
NOT THAT PEOPLE WERE AFRAID TO
SAY THINGS, THEY WERE AFRAID TO
THINK.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU THINK, YOU
START TALKING.
THIS WAS FOR ME, AS AN AMERICAN
KID, 25.
THAT WAS THE MOST FRIGHTENING
THING.
I SAW PEOPLE WOULD NOT THINK.
THEY WERE CONTROLLING THEIR
THOUGHTS.
SO AS NOT TO SAY.
>> RIGHT OUT OF 1984.
>> WE TAKE IT FOR GRANTED.
OUR FREEDOMS THAT WE HAVE.
FREEDOM OF SPEECH, EXPRESSION,
RELIGION.
EVERYTHING.
IT'S ALL FREEDOM.
IT'S ALL THERE.
WHEN YOU COME TO A SOCIETY LIKE
THAT, YOU SHOULD VALUE THE
FREEDOMS THAT YOU HAVE.
WHAT PUTIN HAS DONE IS TO TAKE
TEN YEARS OF DEMOCRACY, THE FALL
OF THE IRON CURTAIN, THE BREAK
OF THE SOVIET UNION WHICH FOR
HIM, HE SAID WAS ONE OF THE
GREATEST CATASTROPHES OF THE
20th CENTURY, AND HERE HE IS NOW
TRYING TO BRING IT BACK AND WHAT
HE'S ACCOMPLISHING, HE'S
CREATING A LITTLE NORTH KOREA OR
BIG NORTH KOREA ON THE TERRITORY
OF RUSSIA AND I THINK THAT'S A
VERY, VERY FRIGHTENING MOMENT.
>> AND YOUR THOUGHTS ON
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY'S
LEADERSHIP?
JEWISH PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE.
>> HE'S NOT THE JEWISH
PRESIDENT.
HE'S THE PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE
WHO HAPPENS TO BE JEWISH.
HOWEVER, I MUST TELL YOU THAT
YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY,
HE'S A VERY, VERY POPULAR GUY.
EVERYBODY LOVES HIM AS A ACTOR.
EVERYONE, AS A COMEDIAN.
BESIDES MAYBE SOME OF THE PEOPLE
HE'S MAKING FUN OF.
HE'S UNBELIEVABLE.
WHEN HE BECAME PRESIDENT, HE HAD
A TREMENDOUS, TREMENDOUS SURGE
OF POPULARITY.
72%.
THEN IT STARTED WANING AS YOU DO
AS POLITICIANS, BUT I THINK HE
HAS SHOWN LEADERSHIP IN A WAY
THAT NOBODY EVER BELIEVED.
YOU KNOW, WHEN A MAN IS, HE
KNOWS THAT HE'S BEING HUNTED AND
HE KNOWS HE'S BEING HUNTED BY
ONE OF THE GREATEST NUCLEAR
POWERS, HIS NEIGHBOR WHO WANTS
TO KILL HIM.
AND HE SAYS I WILL NOT GIVE UP.
WHEN HE'S OFFERED A RIDE OUT, HE
SAYS DON'T OFFER ME A RIDE,
OFFER ME WEAPONS.
HE HAS RAISED THE MORALE AND
SPIRIT OF THE PEOPLE IN UKRAINE.
EVERYBODY'S PROUD OF HIM.
WHY THE PEOPLE OF UKRAINE ARE
WILLING TO FIGHT.
I'M IN TOUCH WITH MY COMMUNITY
24/7.
EVACUATING PEOPLE, TAKING THEM
OUT.
BUT THERE ARE MANY PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY WHO SAY I WILL NOT
EVACUATE.
I'M GOING TO STAY TO FIGHT.
I EVEN HAD PEOPLE EVACUATING TO
THE WEST THEN SAID RABBI, I HAVE
TO GO BACK.
I CAN'T DO THIS.
I HAVE TO GO BACK AND FIGHT.
I THINK ALL OF THIS, YOU KNOW,
THE FIGHTING WE'RE SEEING,
SOMETHING I THIN